[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces passagers et de trouver des
ressources à chaque fois et
durant les récents assauts table
[Musique]
e
et
ans
non
[Musique]
on a dit non
non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours aimé lire dès que j'ai pu
comprendre le sens des mots je me suis
lancé dans la lecture à corps perdu je
me servais largement dans la
bibliothèque familiale il faut dire
qu'elle était bien garnie entre jack
london
jules verne paul emile victor antoine de
saint-exupéry qui n'avaient que
l'embarras du choix
ils étaient tous là mais parmi tous les
livres que j'ai dévoré celui qui met le
plus cher aujourd'hui c'est celui ci
c'est le tout premier livre que m'est
offert ma grand-mère alors que je
n'avais que cinq ou six ans après l'âge
de ma fille que vous voyez sur l'image
ce livre je les lui ai relu parfois tard
dans la nuit à la lumière d'une petite
lampe de poche
j'en ai mémorisées chaque ligne chaque
dessin chaque détail
tant et si bien que son héros était
devenu comme un ami avec lequel je
partageais des secrets ce livre c'était
toute une atmosphère un monde
merveilleux et inaccessible qui me
fascinait je ne sais pas s'il a joué un
rôle décisif dans les choix de vie qui
ont été les miens par la suite mais je
sais qu'il a laissé une sacrée empreinte
dans ma mémoire
j'imagine que nous avons tous un objet
un livre une musique un lieu qui nous
relie à notre enfance et nous rappelle
nos rêves de gamin mais j'imagine aussi
que certains d'entre nous ici on
rangeait depuis longtemps rêvé objets ou
qu'ils les ont laissés se délayer avec
le temps pourtant si on y réfléchit
il n'était peut-être pas aussi futiles
qu'on veut bien le croire
dans notre quotidien on se laisse
souvent submergé par toutes sortes de
questions un sens qu'on voudrait donner
à notre existence leur gré d'occasions
ratées on s'essouffle pour rester dans
la course jusqu'au moment où tout ça
nous paraît complètement absurde et
c'est souvent là que ressurgit notre
rêve
peut-être pas exactement celui qu'on
faisait en font mais un rêve qui nous
donne envie de tout larguer mettre les
voiles de changer de cap
rêver c'est déjà nourrir une idée une
envie alors on s'emballe on y croit on
tire des plans sur la comète et puis on
se laisse happer à nouveau par le
quotidien et les choses restent comme
elles sont en traversant l'atlantique à
la rame puis en kiteboat en allant
frotter au pacifique puis à l'océan
arctique et en poursuivant ainsi ma
route je veux bien au delà de mes rêves
j'essaye de donner un sens à ma vie je
deviens qui je suis
tout au fond de moi on ne sait pas 100 g
ainsi une impression de trouver ma place
d'être exactement à l'endroit où je dois
être là où je peux me réaliser
pleinement et m'exprimer entièrement
nous avons tous une place sur cette
terre et il me semble bien que en osant
suivre nos rêves
c'est une belle façon de la trouver si
on en dise identifie nos vrais désirs et
qu'on franchisse ce premier cas on
réalise vite l'énergie comme un petit
moteur intérieur qui se met en route
c'est qu'il nous pousse vers l'avant on
se libère alors de nous entre havas et
abat on peut franchir les étapes
suivantes
évidemment on ne traverse pas
l'atlantique à la rame du jour au
lendemain ça se prépare est plutôt
minutieusement
cela dit je partie d'un univers que je
connaissais déjà pour avoir navigué
depuis mon plus jeune âge
mais je l'avais mis de côté lorsque je
suis parti vivre dix années aux états
unis à ce moment là je pourrai après
autre chose jusqu'au moment où j'en ai
eu marre j'ai fait mes valises
je suis rentré en bretagne pendant mon
absence
mon père avait construit une yole en
bois
c'est grâce à elle que j'ai renault avec
l'océan c'est grâce à elle aussi que
j'ai réalisé à quel point cet univers
m'avait manqué alors après avoir ramé
sur le même plan d'eau pendant des mois
j'ai eu envie de sortir du cadre aller
plus loin et aller plus loin quand on
est bretonne elle construite l'horizon
passer de l'autre côté
simplement ça a été comme un déclic une
évidence
traverser l'atlantique à la rame et en
solitaire c'était ça que je voulais
faire et pas autre chose donc deux ans
après mon retour des états unis
mais voilà au beau milieu de l'océan sur
un bateau de la taille d'une voiture en
un peu plus spartiate un espace à
l'avant pour stocker la nourriture et
l'équipement d'un cockpit central pour
le moteur moi en l'occurrence haineux
cabine à l'arrière qui à l'image ou
petites tentes qu'on jette et qui se
déploie me sert d'abri
je me retrouve tout à coup minuscule
face à l'immensité ballotté entre le
ciel et la mer
je comprend très vite que il va falloir
m'adapter car sur ce terrain la moindre
erreur peut coûter très cher je vous
assure c'est fou les ressources qu on se
découvre dans ces moments là
cette capacité d'adaptation qui est la
nôtre sans doute parce que tous nos sens
sont en éveil mais certainement aussi
parce qu'on a pas d'autre choix
sortir de sa zone de confort nous
fragilise nous perturber là tous vécu à
un moment ou à un autre une expérience
nouvelle et on se trouve complètement
déstabilisé par ce que tous nos codes
deviennent totalement inconnu il y a
quelques années de ça mon téléphone
satellite est tombé en panne
je venais de quitter les côtes du pérou
et je ralliait la polynésie environ 7000
kilomètres plus loin en solitaire cette
anecdote peut sembler anodine pour un
terrien mais pour un marin ce téléphone
c'est le seul et unique lien avec la
terre et réciproquement
c'était le 11 mars 2011
je sais pas si vous en souvenez mais mon
sponsor venait de m'appeler pour
m'annoncer l'accident nucléaire de
fukushima
un tsunami étaient attendues sur les
côtes péruviennes
il fallait que je m'en éloigne au plus
vite et puis et puis plus rien
la communication a été coupée comme ça
arrive souvent avec les téléphones
satellites
je me suis pas vraiment inquiété tout de
suite j'ai attendu une heure j'ai
réessayé rien deux heures sur
trois heures toujours rien j'ai attendu
une journée puis deux puis trois je vous
jure quand les comptes et au bout d'une
semaine il a bien fallu je me rende à
l'évidence j'étais définitivement coupés
du reste du monde est à terre personne
ne savait réellement ce qu'il en était
de moi le temps s'est arrêté
la solitude a pris son véritable sens et
dans les premiers jours j'ai eu
l'impression de disparaître comme gommer
du monde des vivants et plus je cogitais
plus derrière
j'imaginais que une partie de la planète
avaient été rayés de la carte que
peut-être la polynésie avait disparu
submergée par une vague gigantesque
quand on est seul
le doute s'installe et que la fatigue
nous bruit sacrément l'esprit c'est
difficile de garder le bon cap jusqu'au
moment où on lâche prise et qu'on
accepte la situation
j'étais vivante le bateau avancer dans
la bonne direction
l'objectif resté le même pas de
changement majeur sur l'horizon la seule
solution c'était de continuer la route
coûte que coûte
et c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait
j'ai continué pendant 78 jours seul et
au bout de la route
j'ai trouvé la polynésie mais j'ai
trouvé bien plus que ça encore toute
entreprise présente des risques
vous le savez je le savais affronter des
mauvaises conditions météo
gérer une avarie chavirage
c'était des situations pour lesquelles
je m'étais préparé avant le départ une
catastrophe nucléaire pas franchement
c'est elle qui m'a permis de comprendre
que malgré une préparation minutieuse et
bien qu ayant anticipé de nombreux
pièges
il y avait toujours une part d'imprévu
qu'il fallait être prêt à accepter que
ce soit un cargo le 200 m qui fait route
sur moi qui ne m'a pas vu malgré mes
nombreux appels à la vhf ou un ouragan
qui change sa route qui vient de frapper
de plein fouet
ça peut être aussi l' annonce du décès
de quelqu'un de proche qu'on ne serrera
pas dans ses bras à l'arrivée dans ces
heures noires mieux au faire le dos rond
laisser les choses se pose et éviter que
les émotions ne submerge ces moments là
ce sont comme des virages sinueux
il faut négocier habilement pas des culs
de sac
en tout cas ils ne doivent jamais être
une excuse pour ne rien faire parce que
s'empêcher de vivre par peur de mourir
c'est pas la solution
partout dans le monde tous les jours des
tas de gens meurent et pas plus ceux qui
ont décidé de suivre leur rêve que les
autres on me répond souvent que c'est
pas pareil que je prends plus de risques
que je joue avec la mort mais la vie en
elle-même est imprévisible et la mort
frappe quand elle veut qu'ils vous je me
suis d'ailleurs souvent demandé si m la
peur de la mort ne cachez pas plutôt une
peur de vivre tout simplement
actuellement je prépare ma prochaine
expédition solaire en solitaire je
repars l'été prochain
gfr
dans ce passage du nord ouest qui est
mythique et légendaire là-haut dans le
cercle arctique entre l'alaska et le
groënland
je vois referais à bord d'un petit
prototype uniquement propulsé à
l'énergie solaire j'embarquerai pour
aller naviguer dans le sillage d' à bout
de siac le petit eskimos dont l'enfance
[Applaudissements]
tapie
c'est pas fini d'en vivre
peut-être certains d'entre vous l'ont lu
de paul emile victor il ya beaucoup de
magie mais là où dans l'arctique
très honnêtement il y en a bien plus
encore il y a deux étaient de ça ma
route a croisé celle de la nec
le roi de l'arctique l'ours polaire
tout à coup ils étaient là plus un
dessin imprimé sur une feuille de papier
bien vivant imposant à 300 mètres devant
moi lui super à l'aise m'avait repéré
depuis très très longtemps
moi complètement statufié j'avais rien
vu venir
je vous jure que en quelques secondes on
se sent complètement démunis est
insignifiant comme vous voyez là je suis
en sécurité
je suis encore un peu aux aguets l'ours
traîne dans le coin et je voudrais
éviter de lui servir de casse croûte
je suis inquiète
mais je me souviens très bien à quel
point j'étais excitée comme une gamine
qui venaient voir le père noël parce que
cette rencontre au final ça a été une
des plus belles rencontres de mon voyage
elle en a fait toute la magie accomplir
son rêve ouvre la porte à de nouveaux
comportements comme ce petit canot il
appartient à ed ed c'est un canadien de
75 ans que j'ai rencontrés lors de mon
tout premier séjour à double take two qu
ils venaient parcourir 1500 km tout seul
le long du fleuve mackenzie
il était complètement épuisé mais
tellement fière d'avoir réalisé 100
de boeuf il était plutôt petits pas très
costaud pas du tout un athlète mais la
force n'est pas toujours ce qu'on croit
elle ne se mesure pas toujours à la
masse musculaire ou aux kilos de fonte
qu'on est capable de soulever la force
dead tout au long de ses 1500 km a été
tout supporter sans baisser les bras et
c'est ça qui est remarquable
cette force qui existe en chacun de nous
accomplir son rêve ouvre la porte à de
nouveaux comportements
un regard neuf aussi tension nous mêmes
que sur les autres on réalise alors que
nos ressources sont bien au delà des
barrières qu'on s'était fixé et que
finalement on est à la hauteur de pas
mal de situations que nous redoutions
depuis quinze ans que je pars pour les
océans je réalise la faible chance que
j'ai offerte à mon existence de donner
ce tout premier coup drame et plus j'y
retourne plus je suis persuadé qu'il
appartient à chacun nous de partir à la
recherche de son ours polaires de
manière instinctive au fond de soi pour
tendre vers d'autres horizons
merci
[Applaudissements]